happy father's day everybody
if you're a father if you have um
fathered something
if you'd ejaculated out of your body and
that grew up somewhere
then that means you bubby
that means you're a daddy you're a dad
or a step-dad even now
they got that second string dad that
back up
the mark brunell
of parents you know that step daddy
and a lot of those men will get
mustaches as well a lot of time you see
a step dad gets that
you know it's like the sheriff's badge
of step dad just that mustache baby that
dirty word curtain baby you know what
i'm talking about
that
um
that mustache ah
but yeah happy father's day everybody if
you did it and if you enjoyed it um
it's it's a it's a nice day i think for
commemoration
you know a nice day to stop and
and look at the just you know really
think about the ball bag you came out of
you know and um
it's interesting that god and mother
nature use a ball bag to get you out
into the world
it's kind of exciting really to think
that the first thing you did was flew
out of somebody's wiener
and it's like going for a damn jog right
out of just you know
i mean that's crazy
it's crazy when you think that the first
thing you ever did was that you know
that you you flew out of somebody's
penis bruh
that's i mean this
it's real bravo it's adventurous
it's damn brave of you
so next time if you're looking at you
know a mountain you know climbing up
something or doing a water slide you're
like i can't do it
okay man baby you know you can
you know you can
um
you know my dad was real old uh
my dad he was a senior citizen when i
was born
and um
you know i have some memories i i wish i
had more memories of him
that's what i wish i had
oh
and when you're real young you're not
thinking about making memories with your
dad that's not you don't think about you
know it's the dad's more his
responsibility kind of to think let's
make some memories together
and uh
yeah my dad man i remember he used to do
this game too he would
put us on our belly you know my dad
would put me on my belly on the ground
or on a carpet indoor ground
and
he put change he'd get as much change as
he had in his in his pocket
and he put it on my back
and he'd say okay if you could you know
turn oh if you can get up
and
without any change falling off your back
you can keep the change if you can kind
of turn around and get
and uh
and it's impossible i never could do it
and i would get furious and i would
never get any money from him
and he also never even i don't think
paid child support later on
so you know so it's uh
happy father's day guys we'll get into
it you know a lot i know a lot of you
guys are fathers out there and uh
congratulations and uh i hope you
enjoyed your day i hope you felt loved
by your family and um let's see what uh
the world has for us here again
come on baby
that classic baby
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be so far from my
home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
[Music]
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share
[Music]
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself go wild
shine that light on me
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
just
[Music]
there we are baby that's shined by
bishop gunn and you know that that's
really the
that's the national anthem of this
podcast
you know that right there
that's that damn national anthem
of this podcast
what's going on what's good in the world
we're coming up on summer solstice
and that's that long day baby
that's swear today i mean the day just
had that extended cab
you know that's where the day really
just stretches its legs out
you can see the clock doing yoga over
there it's getting long
that's summer solstice baby
you look in the distance man you'll see
uh
you see dracula or wolver wolves or any
type of nighttime in them you see them
over there looking at their watch like i
should you know am i late for work
you see any nighttime creatures or
critters
you see them looking at they want me
come on man
i must be late for work
because the day just the day really just
punches the night time right in the damn
night deck
and that's what happens baby because the
day just does it all
that it can
on that summer solstice that thing is
long
it's a long day
it's a good day to uh
to spend time with somebody you care
about to do a little something extra
you know if you usually just go right
home there's not enough time you go hey
let's take the long way home
let's drive by and see see something
see something
or do something go check a sunset
take a little ladybird out there with
you to the sunset
touch on each other a little bit
do something right let the cops pull up
what are y'all doing
touching each other
all right
sometimes if you tell them honestly
they'll just drive off you know
guy remember one time pulled up on me i
was over there by a lake
and the cop pulled up what are you doing
i'm like
feeling on some tits and he drove off
bro he honked twice as he drove off too
bro
damn pervert creep
probably still employed over there
probably sheriff now
what's happening man um
i'm going to florida this week and so
i'm i'm excited about that down there in
florida anything could happen down there
a lot of danger bears out there
you know that's where they uh you got
people you know just
you got people down there eating their
own lips and stuff you know it's real
florida it's just
a lot going on there
you have people some people don't even
can't even
use prepositions you'll meet somebody
they can't they can't use any
prepositions they don't have somebody
with them that that does only use this
preposition
and they'll start talking and then they
pat the person on the back when they
need a preposition and that person will
say a preposition
you just get some weird uh
people down there pairings you know
it's really the bermuda triangle of
genetics down there
a lot of people just gargling their own
tongues down there yeah everything
you know a lot of you you know you punch
somebody in the back and a damn percocet
will fly out of them
you don't know what's going on
you'll grab somebody weaner made out of
fentanyl or something you know it's just
you just have so much possibility there
because so much drugs could float in on
the banks there's so much bank you know
that the water really gets to molest
that whole state almost
you know when you got water just sucking
on the sides of your land
you know there's gonna be a lot of uh
that's really that's almost you know the
beach is kind of like it's almost like
the water giving the land of uh bj if
you look at it just keeps kind of
so you know florida's about to pop off
dawg because the way it's just get it's
getting really getting slurped on by the
atlantic and the uh
g of mex over there
praise god but i'll be down there in
hollywood florida this week
so if you know anybody over there near
for uh near fort lauderdale
and maya ma
come down there to hollywood florida
fort myers florida that's on this friday
june 24th hollywood on the 23rd
then daytona beach
over there a good day to just smoke
cigarettes until your tits cave right
into your damn body
like a lot of you know you see a lot of
that out there
a lot of adult women that look like um
dog the bounty hunter
over there in detona beach florida
and then lakeland florida on uh june
26th i'm excited for all of that
we also we got these new t-shirts in and
a couple of other styles be good to
yourself summertime colors banana salmon
and more theovonstore.com
oh what's happening with me
um
[Music]
i went to a bonafire yesterday a
bonafire somebody invited me
and it's just
anytime somebody invites you to a big
bonafire you gotta really
wonder how if they trying to be around
satan or not
because there's all you know
it's all they always do a little extra
at those things people start you know
once it they start the bonafire some
people start throwing other [ __ ] in
people you know let's burn let's burn
this
you know then somebody drive back to
their house gets all their ex-wife's
stuff and brings all that [ __ ] up and
people throwing you know
and then somebody some dude goes and
gets his ex-wife and throws that and you
know it's like damn
it just
it creates a lot of havoc sometimes if
somebody does a bonafire
uh yeah father's day man i remember you
know
my my dad wasn't
my dad was
around but he was
i don't know i was just so young you
know just so young
when my dad lived with my parents got
divorced when i was seven
and uh
and after that my dad would try to come
over on the weekends and drive and see
us
but he was getting older he was 77 78 at
that point
and so we started hitting stuff on you
know he had to drive about 30 40 miles
to get to us and he would hit stuff and
they'd have to you know say hey can't
come he hit this or he hit
a ditch and then it would escalate ditch
car
you know
um
not embankment but you know he hits you
know he just and then finally he just
couldn't really come and see us that
much anymore
um
but yeah i have some fond memories you
know my dad his
he he
uh he would smell like beer sometimes
and i like you know some some sometimes
i remember that a little
and
my dad liked to whistle he would whistle
a lot
and his eyes would water he would be
whistling in his eyes would be kind of
leaking
and because he was just old i'll be like
you know i always thought he was sad but
he just old because when you get old
your body just start you start crying at
you know everything
you know you just start dripping
if you walk up to an old person right
now and hand them like a towel or
something or kleenex they'll they'll say
thank you and they'll dry something off
that's just old people they leaking bruh
you go up to an old person right now you
give them a little towelette
you know a little a little french towel
or a little gay towel or whatever it is
you know
you know i think it's a towelette huh
if it's trying to bang other boy towels
bruh that's a towelette son
you know that praise god
but uh
you give give a towelette to when a
senior citizen i still dry something off
on the spot they leaking bro
they leaking man
um
what do we have
in the news joe biden off his bike
couldn't fault dude can't ride a bike
that good get him off the bike
get that man off of the bike
y'all know he's a senior citizen man
and that's as much citizen as you can
get that's it
okay that dude is right you know
that dude's hanging out right there on
uh
on the lord's doorstep dude
if the lord had a ring cam you would see
uh joe biden's on that thing
so don't tell me he ain't just he ain't
he ain't uh about dead
okay and y'all putting him on a bike and
you should be ashamed of yourself his
wife too
whatever her name is ronald ron
i don't know i don't know what her name
is
but you don't put that you don't put
that man on a damn bike
you don't put a senior citizen like that
on a bike and if you do put them in that
little seat in the back
and let somebody tough out there drive
them around
but damn bro they put the man out there
just [ __ ] [ __ ] crazy bro dude trying
to do stunts and whatever he's doing
it's just
i don't like the way they parade in this
that man around he's just something's
you know he's not well
he's mentally getting older
and he just you can't do it it's not
fair i'm sure other countries look at
him
and they're like damn bro
so i just it's just time to stop you
know
to me it seems sad that we keep putting
him out because he don't seem well
and i think he's brave because he keeps
going out there but damn
get that man off at a damn bike
jeepers
what if somebody walked up and put your
granddaddy on a bike right now
what would you tell him
get him off the bike that's what you'd
tell him
but yeah he fell off his bike
what else we got here more than 2 800
pounds of cocaine disguised as potatoes
dang boy
let's get some potatoes
dude that makes me want to eat potatoes
hello potato
bruh dude
if potatoes is cocaine
i mean you can have somebody you know
you want to have your little cousin
overdose on a damn waffle fry
you know somebody um
you know somebody got fentanyl all
groton
and now you know and now you got to be
at a funeral
it just is somebody going to get their
order supersized and hit the strip club
bro
it's a dark time
you get pulled over by the cops you're
like i only only had two fries bro
i only had two fries bro
[ __ ] man
[Music]
it's just
man
home home fries gonna be called uh
halfway house fries that's gonna be it
that's good because look man you have
too many of them mitch's you're going to
be living with about 11 dudes you never
met
bunk bedding it
and doing meetings three times a day
it's different times baby
oh
this is it this is an interesting thing
i saw
uh a google engineer
who thinks that the company's ai has
come to life
and um
he's now a former employee
and he said he was using their new uh
interactive program
and that it seems a lot more sentient
there's a lot more um
human
characteristics when he's communicating
with this uh artificial intelligence
and that's kind of like
i mean it's
how long before because once as soon as
these things learn to think
and really think and and know how we
operate
they're gonna start talking [ __ ] bro
how long until you're making a piece of
toast bruh and your toaster tells you to
go [ __ ] yourself
huh
you trying to get a little carb square
in you and that thing says go f off bruh
how long until you go to your
refrigerator you try to open it and it
uh
it calls you fat
or it calls you skinny
or it just calls you a little [ __ ] bruh
you didn't have nothing to do with
you're like what i'm trying to get a
damn capri sun bruh damn bruh
and it's like that's [ __ ] liquid
that's [ __ ] liquid
like dang how you know
that's when it's gonna get weird
and you you know whether you're using a
sexual toy and it makes fun of your
crotch or whatever your butt if you gay
fella doing it
how long you know that's just
that's gonna be strange right
when you get in a car and it tells you
to walk
and then it dry it drives next to you
while you walk
and calls you little [ __ ] bruh
or cause you a little f got you know
what i'm talking about
you know it calls you a little soft a
little softy
that's you know
and then it starts doing that thing
where it stops and says it's going to
let you in and it kind of opens it and
then as soon as you run up to get it
takes off and just it keeps stop like
that [ __ ]
but that's going to be where we at man
that's right around the corner
bro that's all it takes dude
you know just one rogue you know blender
of the dishwasher to ruin a family
secret
you hanging out you know you in the kit
you walk through the kitchen and it's
like tom is a pedophile
you know
marjorie got a sex change
like damn bro
i'm not trying to make yellow ham
sandwich dog in the secret that did as
soon as these things know what's going
on
get out the wrapping paper baby
cause it's a rap
okay i want to say that uh you know i
lose my sunglasses a lot i've lost
probably almost i would bet 950 dollars
worth of pairs
um
and i don't want that to happen but i
still want to have quality and that's
where gooder comes in
where else can you find a pair of
sunglasses called mud wrestling with
nedry
not at 7-eleven you won't
luckily our friends at gooder have
created the ultimate sunglasses
collection from a to z
you can pick up a pair called a gingers
soul or going to valhalla
head over to godr.com
theo and use code t-h-e-o for fifteen
percent off
that's gooder g-o-o-d-r dot com slash
t-a-g-o
and use code theo for fifteen percent
off protect your eyes and see the future
with gooder
yeah you can take them with you going to
run you're going to uh you're going to a
benefit or something somebody you know
passed away or something you go on a
fundraiser or there was a fire or
something at a um
you know at a fire at a bakery
and you're going there to raise money
for them over at uncle jeff's bakery
ah they can do it they can help gooder
wear good glasses if you're at a fire if
you're at a fundraiser if you're on a
fun date if you're even just going to
lay there with your body
they're 25 active sunglasses for anyone
100 polarized over 40 thousand five-star
reviews
man they tasty baby here's the pairs
that i picked out right here
gooder is going to give you 15 off your
entire order go to godr.com
that's g-o-o-d-r
dot com slash t-h-e-o get 15 off when
you use code theo at checkout you know i
get tired of drinking coffee
it makes my neck hurt and it makes my
legs sweat
a lot
that's why mud water
is a coffee alternative that i've been
using
it has four adaptogenic mushrooms
and ayurvedic
herbs
it has one-seventh of caffeine as a cup
of coffee
so that's what i noticed i get actual
energy it gives me a slight pickup but
that feels manageable to me coffee to me
sometimes feels
uh
i get the gyration
you know i don't it doesn't feel as
smooth like it just fits with my system
it feels like it attacks my system
and i don't get that crash off of it
mud water don't give you that crash each
ingredient was added for a purpose
they get cacao and chai for mood
lion's mane for alertness cordyceps
to help your physical performance and
turmeric for soreness dang they're doing
it baby
i love it man you can have cinnamon in
it it's got that little tent
it's got you put a little bit of honey
in there nut milk yeah you can put
whatever any you know
milk whatever you want put it in there
damn goat milk whatever you want
whatever you cut you know these days
there you know whatever you can squeeze
something out of get it in there
mud water is whole 30 approved 100 usda
organic non-gmo gluten free vegan and
kosher certified dang
it's got all the merit badges baby mud
water allows you to build a morning
ritual that promotes sustained energy
without the crash that's why i think you
should try it go to mudwtr.com
theo to support the show and use code
theo for fifteen percent off that's
m-u-d-w-t-r-dot-com
t-h-e-o to support the show and use code
theo for fifteen percent off
what else a woman was charged with a
felony after spitting on a corpse in
casket
at a funeral home
hmm
let's see about that according to an
arrest
lori heinz walked into a funeral home in
tyler texas walked straight up to the
casket and spit on the corpse
a witness at the scene a snitch
said hines had animosity towards the
family of the person in the casket
she was arrested
you know i think
i think at a funeral you know if it's
open casket i think it's really um
they should people should be able to
come and have that last little
interaction
and sometimes it's a positive one
sometimes it's not
sometimes you know you see somebody put
a little uh
hot adorail cigarette under somebody's
arm
or put a gum in their mouth
you know you'll see some dirty lady come
up there and rub the dude's wiener one
time hit him with that dirty genie real
quick
you know wishing for you know once more
but i think everybody should that's what
you know if you got the passer by
everybody
come to get your last thing i don't
think you should be able to punch
but i think you know
you should be able to probably uh
i don't even know if spit maybe you spit
on his clothes i don't think spitting on
the you know i don't know maybe if they
wear a shield or something like one of
those plastic uh
shields and you could do it
i don't know
but i think you know a little bit one
more even if somebody calls you a little
pus
you know i think something like it's
like it's still its interaction it's
your last hurrah
so i think getting a little dose or
whatever is okay
and you're at that time if it's still
open baby that's a time capsule
i feel like that's a time capsule you
know people can come by and put in their
affections or put in
uh
their angst
you know she could have wrote a letter
an angry note but sometimes you don't
you don't have time to write an angry
note you just clear your throat him
and that's
you know and just mail that [ __ ] right
to him
short distance baby that's
that's really the same thing as an angry
note i think
so anyway
all right let's take a couple of calls
here
what do we got here
kyle indianapolis
what's up kyle from indianapolis
and um i've been over there before
indianapolis good place man um i've
relapsed over there onward oh man i just
wanted
the dilemma lately man um on the road a
lot and uh sometimes i gotta you know uh
take care of business but uh
i i just i don't enjoy pooping in public
places so um you know i just wanted to
get your thoughts on uh
you know the home court advantage uh
versus an away game you know if anyone
else is having that issue
uh
yeah brother look thank you for calling
man and i'm sorry you're even having to
do it
you know your body can only hold so much
food before it gives up
and it has to do a bm
and there's nothing you're not doing
anything wrong or anything you're not a
bad guy you know you're not a p you know
you're not a um
you know a little wuss or whatever your
neighbor call you you're nothing like
that you're a regular guy and you've
just had too much food over a certain
period of time
um
and yeah i think one of the major issues
is back in the day men would they worked
close to where they lived
you know a man worked at the bank and he
lived four blocks from the bank
you know and that you know that's a
close amount that's a shitter's distance
they used to call it
so a man could go and do a bm at home
or uh
there's sometimes a man would even have
a camper
and they'd do it in a camper but now
yeah you're tr you know or you know
so people worked near where they
defecated
and so now though you have been flying
around the world and traveling and being
uh you know you fly across the world and
sell cement to somebody
you know and
or you know you do it you you know you
drive down the damn um
uh you'll drive over there to uh
to um boise and sell them some cabinets
or something and you should you crapping
the whole way to air and back
crapping in other people's lands and
other people's territories
and yeah and your body gets nervous when
you get further from home too
you know it used to be there's like an
old
wives tale if you read a lot of like uh
native american literature or
about some other habits
if they walk too far if they had to do a
bm it would be their body telling them
nerves would do that
so they would even defecate around an
area and then come back just to if they
went near there again the scent would
warn them
uh
this is uncomfortable territory
so there's a lot of stuff built into
that man and i'm sorry you're dealing
with it and um
and you know i'm the kind of guy i i
will usually kind of plan ahead
and that's what i think you should do
bud get you a little timer or put a
little
uh
you know do a little
bm timer or something
dude my grandmother whenever i would go
to the anytime i'd go in the bathroom at
her house she would beat on the door and
ask me if i was doing a bm or not
and i just think that's just the r
that's just insane ass just you know
dude i'll tell you uh i got this crazy
so i was in
seattle one night and i
i ran into the bathroom and there's a
guy working in there right there's a
brother in there in the bathroom
so i run in there and i had to do a bm
and
it was it was one of the guys who works
in there you know he's got cologne he's
putting a mint on you
and um
you know and all it just does all of
that towels you off the doodle [ __ ]
hug gift for an extra dollar all of that
[ __ ]
you know five extra dollar he'll call
you the n word for ten you give him slip
him ten he'll call you the n word
and uh so anyway i run in there i'm
wrong you know i'm just i gotta go i'm
far from home
so i sit on the uh
i go it's the second i close the door
he's like don't worry dog i got you bruh
like what does that mean i got you right
and
and now i'm like what the hell you know
like i don't
because sometimes those guys when you're
washing your hands they'll like put the
towel out before you're done and now you
feel like you're obligated to do
business right
so now i'm just like what uh i got you
what does this guy mean you know he's
like he hit on the door don't worry dog
i got you
all right uh
so anyway a couple minutes later some
guy
comes in there and tries to pull on the
door
right
and this dude comes over and he's like
hey man my mans is in there give him a
minute right i'm like [ __ ] what
i don't know
i don't know i don't know either one of
these guys out here right
bro 30 seconds later the guy is
like kind of banging on the door like i
didn't hear him
[Music]
just a minute ago like i
you know like i
i don't know like i left through the
ceiling or something and you know when
he's banging on the door and then the
about the bathroom the
[ __ ] bouncer or whatever this guy is he
pushes the dude he's like hey bro i told
you
give my man some room bro and now i'm
like what is going on dude these guys
start pushing each other right
so there's like a melee people come in
there
uh security comes in there and the whole
now there's like 12 people in this
bathroom bro
and i'm still in there dude
just far from home bro
and um
anyway i don't know where that's the
story didn't really end it's just kind
of
but
it's just crazy when you have dudes
fighting because you're trying to
you know
do do
do a bm or do a poop out of your
body so
what else do we have man let's take
another call that came in a lot of
beautiful calls here
that come into uh the hotline
yo theo this is matt from uh huntington
beach california
love the show my man appreciate you
uh you had me dying i just had to call
in because
i used to work at disneyland and i can
one thousand percent verify that it is
the horniest place
uh i have ever worked by far
everybody is having sex with each other
uh gay straight it doesn't matter i used
to uh
operate all the rides uh in fantasyland
so that's like
you know peter pan and alice in
wonderland oh yeah and at the end of the
night straights and gays you heard him
fellas
and ladies onward
uh you have to pair up in groups of two
to walk through the ride to make sure
that no one left a purse or you know
there's not some lost kid in there or
whatever right
so that is where everyone hooks up so
people like if you're if you think
someone is you know
cute or whatever you know you'll be like
hey you know do you want to walk through
peter pan with me tonight you know
i see
bro you know will be the most
embarrassing you come out and uh
she's like it's a small world after all
and she's talking about your
penis okay bad joke that's okay thanks
dad um
but yeah that's what they're doing and
you can smell it if you go in there
early i bet you can still smell that
musk
from people being in love
or sex you know people doing sex
straight
and gay styles
it's all in there and that's disneyland
baby they'll do it
everybody's out there
and they're doing sex by the rides
so i would be too
you know
i mean hell i get a new damn dirt bike
and i'll try and [ __ ] near that thing
so
it doesn't surprise me but thank you for
that on the street intel boots on the
ground they're matt
from disneyland
and it's a real uh
[ __ ] mecca down there people doing sex
and
looking at each other's bodies and all
of that it's time for your crotch health
baby
people's crotches at this time of year
at this juncture of the calendar
people's crotches go bad
bad with moisture
it's too much
so you got to have breathability in your
pants you got to put some gills by your
nuts
that's right
manscaped is helping
they even trademarked the jewel pouch
so you know it's serious
take care of your family jewels with the
most comfortable boxer briefs
out there that's right from manscaped
let your bulge breathe and get twenty
percent off right there and free
shipping by using code t-h-e-o at
manscaped.com
that jewel pouch is designed to cradle
them nuts or nut if you had cancer
and they line with perforated
performance fabric
keep them nuts chill baby them cold nuts
that's what you want
get twenty percent off and free shipping
with code t-h-e-o keep your nuts chill
at manscape.com chill you nuts out
that's twenty percent off in free
shipping with code th eo at
manscaped.com
once the boxers 2.0 touch your sack
you will not
go back
yeah yeah yeah you know it
your wiener soft a lot of times i hold
my wiener at night
before i go to bed i think it's what a
lot of men do if they're unmarried
you know they hold their wiener at night
and fall asleep
and that's okay i think it's okay i
don't know i've never even said that out
loud or asked anybody but blue chew
they can help you
if you want to harden up that boy you
know what i'm saying
if you want to get that thing wanded out
and do magic on someone
blue chew
if you need that extra confidence when
it's time for sex blue chew can help
they're chewable or chew apple
licensed medical providers work with you
to find the right ingredient and
strength for your prescription
it's an online prescription service
that's what it is no visit to the doctor
no having to show them your penis when
it's not hard
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
ships right to your door and discreet
packaging nobody will know not even your
family or wife or children
they can help i've used them many things
i eat i chew half of one and they taste
good and sometimes i forget and eat the
whole thing bruh
and i got that kickstand baby let the
cat let the cat take a couple bats at it
and guys here's a special deal for you
try bluetooth free when you use our
promo code th eo at checkout just pay
five dollars shipping that's b l u e c h
e w dot com code theo to receive your
first month for free that's free
enhancement free thickening on that dong
baby dong up
all right all right all right
and it is father's day man and
you know it's a trying time for some
father's day because uh
you know life is what it is you know i
i uh
you know my father passed away when i
was 16 and
um
[Music]
and it was tough because i was going
through those years where i was um
i was ki you're kind of you know you're
you're teenager
so your body your loins is popping and
you got acne and you're trying to you
know
you're trying to just rock it right you
know god i mean you could damn you could
clear your throat and have a bunch of
dang seed see semen in your mouth of
your own
i mean that's how viral you are
and uh
and so it for that at that time for me i
i wasn't you know i didn't have a strong
relationship with my dad and
um
and i was honestly i was kind of ashamed
of him i was embarrassed i was
embarrassed because he was so much older
and uh
yeah i was embarrassed to him
[Music]
i remember one time i was on a date
with a gal beautiful gal
and uh i was with her family actually
and
we're at a restaurant and my dad was
there
and i
introduced him as my grandfather i tried
like kind of
i said this is my pops kind of kind of
like hid the word like dad and like kind
of just disguise it so like they
wouldn't know but they i could also then
tell them it was my grandfather you know
um
[Music]
and i just felt i felt embarrassed about
that for i don't know i think part of me
maybe i don't still feel him bad i mean
i was i was embarrassed about i was
embarrassed of him he was just so you
know
it was just embarrassing you're at those
eight those years where you want to be
so on your own that
it's hard enough having a parent you
know
being like having a parent right there
and then even tougher is if the parent
isn't doesn't seem like everybody else
parent
you know so
but we've had some calls man recently of
people that have uh struggled uh with um
that it might be a tough father's day
for them let's get into a couple of
those
what's up theo uh this is michael
uh living out of eugene oregon
amen baby eugene oregon
and they've never found him dude
but they still got a place named after
him praise god i'm just calling you know
just been down
i lost my father in uh
last september
it was only 58. um
actually uh
colgate is actually what took him
but it's not really kobe there was a
it was battling cancer for three years
without any of our knowledge never told
me about it
i'm really angry and emotional
like
it's taken me months to really get
emotional honestly i just woke up
feeling sad and
angry angry he didn't tell me
we never really had a good relationship
but
you know i have three kids i grew up
without grandparents
i'm just angry i don't understand why
i understand why he didn't tell me
anything about his health this man was
fighting cancer
his kidneys were failing
man yeah i'm sorry dude i'm sorry uh
i'm sorry about this
i'm sorry about this man i'm sorry that
yeah it seemed like you didn't have the
relationship that you wanted for sure
and
uh
and then yeah he didn't give you any
information oh
yeah my dad got a uh cancer too man and
and
it was a surprise but
um
yeah if he'd have tried to do it and not
even tell me um
[Music]
yeah i could imagine how much that would
hurt because not only was he not there
when you needed him but he wasn't even
he didn't give you enough of a of uh say
hey here's an opportunity for you to
to know that i'm not gonna be around
oh
yeah
yeah man i'm sorry about that dude um
man
that would that would uh i would hurt me
too um
i appreciate you sharing it brother
um i appreciate you hitting the hotline
and sharing about this um and since it's
father's day man i'm just gonna check in
with you
you know uh i wanted to do this today
um
hello big mike what's up man it's theo
oh my goodness how you doing phil i'm
doing good man what's going on with you
nothing man i'm just here with my kids
my wife we're just having a family day
you know
oh nice man so you got a family of your
own huh
yes sir i have a three kids uh
uh soon to be 15 in a high high schooler
a 10 year old and a 9 year old
oh you got a whole flock baby
dang man
i just wanted to tell you man i really
appreciate the phone call
it's honestly like
you made my whole year man i just wanted
to say i think thank you so much man i
love you bro i really do i just want to
say i appreciate you oh thanks bro i
appreciate that man did you get my
voicemail i left you
i did i did man okay cool
if i i have my wife's like
uh theo caught you i was like well i had
to i just went into roth to go get some
sweatpants or something like theo caught
you i was like what what are you talking
about i freaked out and i was like no
way
but
man just
yeah i don't i honestly i i don't i
probably
i hate to like leave
you like sad voice messages because i
feel like you know you're i know you're
a super strong person and everything but
i feel like
sometimes too much sad energy comes your
way sometimes i didn't even i know i've
sent like some voice messages just
saying how much i love your comedy and
stuff so i'm sorry that you have to hear
the one that you know uh i'm sending
that like sad energies to so
oh man
nah pretty look man i appreciate i
appreciate you just sharing kind of what
was going on especially you know yeah i
was just thinking of you man i was
looking back through some voicemails and
uh since it was father's day i was like
let me touch back
and uh and just kind of see what's going
on and
and it sounds like you kind of come to
terms with that with a lot of that or at
least you just find a joy in your own
family huh
yeah um yeah man you know i
lost my father so last year lost my
father and it was a lot more than just
he
he technically died from covid but he
had he was fighting cancer for three
years before i even no one knew no one
knew he was fighting cancer yeah that's
what you said man it's crazy
yeah he didn't tell anyone except for
his sister and his sister in town he won
it was a it was a crazy thing i i got to
bring him up i live in oregon eugene
oregon so i got the
he lived in albuquerque which you were
just in not too long ago yes wow over
there
yeah my that's where my dad uh lived and
my brother and my sister live over there
as well but
um
yeah so uh i'm sorry man i'm just
freaking out i'm talking to you right
now i can't even oh bro no it's crazy
it's wild man
well look you know i just uh yeah i just
thought that it was interesting man and
i you know
it is tough when like a day you know you
don't have a lot of things you don't get
left sometimes a lot of stuff or you
didn't get the information you needed
and all that surprise when it feels like
such a surprise it's like the
the craziest thing to surprise somebody
with is that you're
you know you're not going to be there
anymore that's spooky yeah
yeah
for second there you could like me and
my dad like so i grew up
for the most part by myself honestly
like i grew up in arkansas
for a little bit with my mom there and
then i went to live with my dad well
okay sorry i'm originally from
california moved to arkansas when i was
like four moved back to california with
my dad when i was like 11. so i only
lived with my dad for like two years and
then
my brother passed away in 2004 up in
arkansas
and then uh i ended up moving up here
with my grandma uh in 05 to stay stay up
here and live with her and then she she
passed away in 0-5 dang bro you a bad
luck charm dawg
it's just like you and your best friend
your friends always dying in a ditch or
something man i'm telling you
it's dangerous knowing people is
dangerous bro knowing people
every time i shake somebody's hand i
look them in the eye and just i'm like
are you sure you want this smoke you
know
[Laughter]
yeah absolutely
but uh so i grew up up here in eugene
oregon with my my two aunts you know
they took care of me going household
household really never had a room but
you know i had that love and family
around me so
i
at least had that growing up
um i actually want to tell you i don't
know if i said it but
all
with with you know with my dad passes
just opened my eyes to wanting to do
more i think i might have said i tried
to go to boot camp it didn't work out uh
ended up having two bulging discs and
they medically discharged me and then uh
and then i came home and then i had a
job with costco still so i stuck it out
with costco a little bit and then
i tried stand up i've been i've done
stand up like 11 times now dang bro
that's crazy congrats that was that's
crazy yeah that's the craziest man it's
so nuts so i i fought amateur right i'm
actually going to get a
mma wise so i'm in a whole bunch of
stuff right now new new stuff right a
whole new outlook on life makes you want
to go after it especially having three
kids and a wife you know
yeah man sorry i'm so nervous man
what are you talking about man dude no
it sounds like you just got like you
know it sounds like you got a lot of
gifts in your life man and you you know
staying active and stuff that's all you
could do really you know sometimes we
feel like we're supposed to do so much
more but
we're really not you know
you know your comedy especially theo and
comedy in general has helped me through
uh just depression and and life in
general just it's so unhappy you know
you want to put a smile on i put a a
clip of you and and brandon shaw
roasting each other or something you
know i i put a clip of you and tom
segura just funniest moment stuff like
this dude and this this is what puts a
smile on my face i listen to your guys
podcast all the time like
just to be happy dude it's amazing that
you guys put that out there and i just
want to say like i said i i appreciate
you man and i can't believe
i can't believe you haven't called me
man i just want to say thank you that
was awesome thank you bro well thank you
yeah thank you for the call man and
thank you for um
you know just kind of sharing what was
going on and i'm glad that like you know
like
yeah it sounds like you got a lot of
gifts in your life that are keeping you
busy and keeping your heart occupied man
so that's really good and yeah you know
i'm just happy how are you doing theo
i'm doing pretty you know i'm doing my
best man you know i'm feeling definitely
a little bit better but i think some in
some ways i got to take it easier and uh
just get back to like you know
i want to get back to you feeling even
better you know so uh it's been a slow
process but
uh it's all good man i'm just gonna keep
on going baby that's it um yeah
you're amazing dude yeah i know like
it's crazy because it sounds so weird i
know you're like a super strong person
like i i know it's it's hard to be that
super strong person especially being the
person to put on a smile
but that's what makes us
get inspired by you you know what i mean
like
i understand the feelings like
i don't know how to say it you know but
uh
yeah
i think you're the one i appreciate you
man thank you
yeah i appreciate you too man
i wanted to tell you dude i got a fight
august 13th uh my first mma fight in six
years coming up damn
i'm still amateur i'm two and one
but i haven't fought in six years i'm 31
years old you know so get back out there
and bang it baby
i i'm gonna get back out there august
13th it's i've been training for like
the last six months nice i've got i got
down from 210 to 168 right now
you're gonna
you're gonna be a lean deal out there
baby
man
how are you doing how did you how's jiu
jitsu i've been for the past two weeks
i've just been working out so
uh
that's been helping me right now and
um i'll get back in there i haven't been
in there in almost a month now but i'll
get back in there whenever uh
i got to do some yoga and then i'll get
back in there um yeah but we'll work it
i'll figure it out dude but um i'll
check in on you again man i just wanted
to check in and wish you a happy
father's day brother
hey man thank you so much ruth i really
appreciate it and i can't wait until you
become a father theo you're ready man i
can't wait until you get that little
little baby i know i'm ready dude i am
ready i'm i've definitely been feeling
about it you know and i want to make it
happen at some point soon i got to get
me a wife and i'll do it so
do it get it done
and also come out to
also come out to eugene one of these
days or whenever you go to get your tour
going i know it's going now but uh get
portland in there somewhere yeah i'm
gonna do eugene i'm gonna do bend i'm
gonna do all of it i'm gonna come
through yeah
so awesome heck yeah we love you theo i
appreciate you man you have a great day
i really appreciate it man all right
love you too michael good to hear your
voice baby gang
and there you go right there caught back
up with michael um
yeah just powerful to see how things can
change you know how you can go from
feeling one way one day
uh
to feeling i mean he just boosted my
spirits
so
[Music]
you know it's a lot of it is just a
level of patience
and uh realizing that you know those
tough moments are going to pass by
you know that they're on
this is just a conveyor belt man
it's a conveyor belt of feelings and
they
you can grasp onto which ones you want
and sometimes
you touch one and it's not the best one
and
something else come on by that's a
little bit
more to uh
your liking
so
happy to have a moment with him man
thank you michael for that
you know it's wonderful to see how uh
how things change it's just that's
that's such a unique example
you know such an obvious example
how you can be really going through
something at one moment
but that it'll pass
you just got to ride it you know you
just have to
be patient with yourself write it out
or just let time tick
close your eyes
but here he is you know you fast forward
and the moment he was called in he's
caught in a whole different moment now
enjoying his life enjoying his family
living you could hear he could hear him
living
man
i just got to remember that for myself
we all do windows tough when those tough
times come just you know
just hold the line baby
just hold the line
i'm gonna switch back into my uh
actually i'll keep this shirt on
this is a good one
and let's play uh let's let's roll out
the same way we came in baby i'll uh get
us back into it
and happy father's day or father to b
day belated i know it's belated this
will get to you late and that's okay
um
you know and thank you guys for being a
part of my life over the years
i appreciate it i'm excited to see you
guys in florida this week
uh you guys be good to yourselves baby
gang
a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
heavy load
[Music]
they just weren't built
[Music]